so we have the graph of y equals f of x
right over here and we want to figure
out three different limits and like
always pause this video and see if you
can figure it out on your own before we
do it together
all right now first let's think about
what's the limit of f of x as x
approaches 6. so as x let me do this in
a color you can see as x approaches 6
from both sides well as we approach 6
from the left hand side from values less
than 6 it looks like our f of x
is approaching
and as we approach x equals 6 from the
right hand side it looks like our f of x
is once again approaching 1. in order
for this limit to exist we need to be
approaching the same value from both the
left and the right hand side and so here
at least graphically so you never are
sure with the graph but this is a pretty
good estimate it looks like we are
approaching one right over there let me
do the darker color
now let's do this next one the limit of
f of x as x approaches four so as we
approach four
from
the left hand side
what is going on
well as we approach 4 from the left hand
side it looks like our function the
value of our function it looks like it
is approaching 3. remember you can have
a limit exist at an x value where the
function itself is not defined the
function if you said what is f of 4 it's
not defined but it looks like when we
approach it from the left when we
approach x equals 4 from the left it
looks like f is approaching 3.
and when we approach 4 from the right
once again
it looks like our function is
approaching 3.
so here i would say at least from what
we can tell from the graph it looks like
the limit of f of x as x approaches 4 is
3 even though the function itself is not
defined there
now let's think about the limit as x
approaches
2. so this is interesting the function
is defined there f of 2 is 2 let's see
when we approach from the
left hand side
it looks like our function is
approaching the value of 2
but when we approach from the right hand
side when we approach x equals 2 from
the right hand side our function is
getting closer and closer to 5. it's not
quite getting to 5 but as we go from you
know 2.1 2.01 2.001 it looks like our
function the value of our function is
getting closer and closer to five
and since we are approaching two
different values from the left hand side
and the right hand side as
x approaches two from the left-hand side
and the right-hand side we would say
that this limit does not exist so does
not
exist which is interesting in this first
case the function is defined at 6 and
the limit is equal to the value of the
function at x equals 6. here the
function was not defined at x equals
four but the limit does exist here the
function is defined at f equal at x
equals two but the limit does not exist
as we approach x equals two
let's do another function just to get
more cases of looking at graphical
limits
so here we have the graph of y is equal
to g of x and once again pause this
video and have a go at it see if you can
figure out these limits graphically
so first we have the limit as x
approaches 5 of g of x so as we approach
5 from the left hand side
it looks like we are approaching this
value
so let me see if i can draw a straight
line that takes us
so it looks like we're approaching this
value and as we approach 5 from the
right hand side it also looks like we
are approaching that same value
and so this value just eyeballing it off
of here looks like it's about .4
so i'll say this limit definitely exists
just when we're looking at a graph it's
not that precise so i would say it's
approximately
0.4 it might be 0.41 it might be
0.41456789 we don't know exactly just
looking at this graph but it looks like
a value roughly around there
now let's think about the limit of g of
x as x approaches 7. so let's do the
same exercise what happens is we
approach from the left from values less
than 7 6.9 6.99 6.999
well it looks like the value of our
function is approaching 2. it doesn't
matter that the actual function is
defined g of 7 is 5 but as we approach
from the left as x goes 6.9 6.99 and so
on it looks like our value of our
function is approaching 2 and as we
approach x equals 7 from the right hand
side
it seems like the same thing is
happening it seems like we are
approaching 2.
and so i would say that this is going to
be equal to 2. and so once again the
function is defined there and the limit
exists there but the g of 7 is different
than the value of the limit of g of x as
x approaches 7.
now let's do one more what's the limit
as x approaches 1
well we'll do the same thing from the
left hand side it looks like we're going
unbounded as x goes 0.9
0.99 0.999 0.99999
it looks like we're just going unbounded
towards infinity and as we approach from
the right hand side it looks like the
same thing
same thing is happening we're going
unbounded to infinity so formally
sometimes informally people might say oh
it's approaching infinity or something
like that but if we want to be
formal about what a limit means in this
context because it is unbounded we would
say that it does not exist
does
not
exist